m
bonjour c'est impressionnant là bas vous
des succès et donc oui effectivement
donc du fise architectes et le thème de
le thème je vais vous montrer ses terres
fait que human 12.10 blogeuse sait pas
encore très bien ce que ça veut dire pas
c'est exact
thériault de transition et donc on peut
se demander ce qui va devenir peut-être
human triple zéro et en même temps ce
que je voulais vous dire aussi ce que je
voulais vous montrer aussi c'était que
le territoire du réel et le territoire
du virtuel ont-ils un certain moment un
conflit est ce que ce sont deux
territoires qui peuvent se croiser pour
un architecte c'est important parce
qu'un architecte finalement ben est le
premier outil qu'il utilise est une
telle est la peine c'est pas nous qui
l'avons inventé et donc je pense que
c'est important d'arriver à faire la
connexion entre les deux je vous
présente une première
premières images ici c'est pas loin
d'ici
c'est là la reconstruction du centre
d'andenne et donc on voit tout de suite
que dans une reconstruction d'une
collectivité des le réseau s'installe le
réseau s'installe et le réseau
s'installe avec diverses diverses
activités les activités humaines en fait
les activités humains qui n'ont pas
changé des activités humaines qui sont
le commerce mais le commerce dans le
sens étymologique du terme puisque rang
français commerce à veux d'abord dire
échanges après c'est devenu échanges
économiques mais c'est d'abord échanges
et donc vous voyez que quand on
reconstruit ou quand on collabore à la
la reconstruction d'une ville retissage
un tissu urbain et
ne le prenez soucis qu'on a cessé
d'arriver à de façon chirurgicale
presque à reconstruire un tissu qui qui
avait été un petit peu malmené par les
années et pour nous c'était important de
montrer que c'était quelque chose qui
d'abord étaient multiples donc comme
vous pouvez le voir sur la dia bâ il ya
là plusieurs ya plus d'activité il ya
plusieurs actions et puis l'important
aussi c'est le flux et le flux qui soit
sur le territoire du réel où qu'ils
soient sur le territoire du virtuel
savès leflux mais le flux est quelque
chose qui en fait fait un échange humain
et pour nous c'était important d'arriver
à ce que 1,7 à maman d'un cet échange ce
flux puissent être reconstruits
améliorée et si jamais vous avez
occasion donc on joue 10 et à 30 km
d'ici là les voies et puis et puis dites
nous ce que vous en pensez parce que on
se nourrit toujours du regard des autres
c'est aussi un réseau locaux se nourrit
du regard des autres et on est important
de savoir si quand on a osé quelque
chose pendant l'attenté quelque chose
avec des partenaires ils sont publics
qui sont privés si ça plaît si ça
réussit si c'est quelque chose qui a
abouti je pense que c'est important que
nous le sachions je pense que c'est
important aussi de dire que le réseau
virtuel des réseaux virtuels a quand
même ses limites
le réseau virtuel a ses limites parce
que par exemple on nous a toujours dit
on fait des ont fait par exemple d
des complexes commerciaux j'ai dit oui
mais enfin il faut encore des crises
comme cela on le fait différent parce
que ça devient l'un des complexes qui
sont pas seulement les complices
commerciaux mais où il ya la culture où
il ya du sport où il ya des espaces à
vivre voilà est-ce que le lit commerce
le réseau virtuel est en concurrence
avec ceux que nous connaissons où nous
essayons de faire évoluer et je pense
que non je pense que c'est un complément
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'on a mis
ces images là on ne choisit pas parfum
par internet
c'est impossible c'est impossible il
faut il faut un certain moment qui est
ce plaisir charnel ce plaisir physique
de choix et ça le virtuel ne peut pas ne
pas le modifier
on ne choisit pas des ingrédients pour
faire un repas sans pouvoir sentir si on
omet aussi le melon et les murs à bout
va sentir si si la tomate est bien
fermée gars juteuse je pense que ce sont
des choses qui continuent à exister
imaginez un peu pas à distance ou et la
convivialité
il me semble qu'en fait il nous semble
en tout cas que c'est quelque chose qui
qui à un certain moment a ses limites et
c'est important de se comprendre à ses
limites regarder voilà un un repas qui
se passe comme ça je suis pas su ce soir
pas alors je peux faire je préfère
finalement devenir celle c'est cette
image là et plus juste que la suivante
parce que en fait l'art on se demande
pourquoi les gens sont réunis en fait
peut-être qu'ils se parlent d'ailleurs à
jean sérien peut-être qu'ils sont en
train de converser
mais mais
voilà il ya cette distance entre le lieu
la racine et la communication et vous
avez tous connu ce genre de réunions
complètement désagréables ou quand on
est en réunion pour un projet mais tout
le monde a son or ni nature et son et
son iphone ou son smartphone
et puis pour finir on se dit mais
actuellement est ce qu'on entretient la
conversation n'est pas parce que
lee à la une quand même une distorsion
et je pense que justement on doit
dépasser ça et c'est à nous d'apprendre
d'apprendre à dépasser ça je pense juste
à nous apprendre à dépasser ça et à
recréer des lieux avec les des lieux qui
sont des rues les lieux de convivialité
parce que les gens ont toujours besoin
à un certain moment de lieux
d'identification collective on a pris là
quelques images certains d'entre vous
connu ou pas mais il est quand même
étonnant de voir que elahi la
conjonction c'est que quand on annonce
la vente des billets pour le l'événement
dont je ne pouvais plus me souvenir de
nos directives et des moins les 180
mille personnes qui se réunissent au
treuil tomorrowland bravo vous l'avant
scène avant donc tomorrowland une oeuvre
en poupe mais pourquoi faire une pour se
réunir à 180 milles personnes au même
endroit pour célébrer quelque chose
pouvait être dans le même lieu et donc
c'est très important ça le on peut
regarder tous les matchs de foot qu'on
veut à la télé mais touche n'a jamais
autant de gens dans les stades
le jamais eu autant besoin de l'estac y
célébrer un moment un moment de plaisir
du monde convivialité j'ai repris aussi
là au dessus à droite une une image une
place qui a complètement changé à
bruxelles pour ceux qui le connaissent
bruxelles c'est la place de la bourse
la place de la beauce et notre petite
place de la république c'est à dire que
depuis que le petit pas mieux piétonnier
donc tout le monde discute pour tout le
monde a une idée est bien à créer de la
place de la bourse
un espace de collectivités et les gens
s'y réunissent comment par les réseaux
sociaux donc ils s'envoient des messages
en disant teller tel jour il ya une
manifestation sur la place de l'amour
pour telle ou telle expression d'émotion
qu'elle soit positive qu'elle soit de
douleur mais ça se passe toujours comme
ça et je trouve que c'est intéressant de
voir cette complémentarité dans des
réseaux ce qui est important à
comprendre c'est qu'on dise des
mammifères au reste des manifs r17
images la montrent bien depuis longtemps
au reste des mammifères et les
mammifères bay a rien à faire il ya un
côté tactique est ce que tu es tactile
je pense qu'il est important de le
conserver même que ça soit you man to
man divo newman trip en dix ans un
certain moment nous sommes les
mammifères et nous devons le rester
et ces mammifères en fait de quoi qui
nous apprennent des choses nous
apprennent notamment l'intelligence
collective
je sais pas si vous avez déjà eu pour
certains d'entre vous l'occasion d'aller
dans des réserves ici c'est une photo du
serengeti
on voit des moments des transhumances
les troupeaux de gnous et de zèbres qui
traversent des gays et si vous regardez
bien l'image vous voyez cas les
crocodiles qui les attendent
donc vous avez les zèbres des gnous qui
traverse et vous allez les
et crocodile qui attendent on y danse et
jamais viala il avance tout doucement
tout doucement tout doucement et un
certain moment il faudrait presque une
animation vous vous rendez compte que
ces troupeaux s'arrête l'air de dire ok
dit non non ça c'est pas du jeu là vous
êtes trop près et donc et donc ça
s'arrête et il ya il ya des collections
qui se font à une maman gnui une maman
êtes au milieu de dix mille reconnaît le
son de son enfant qui en détresse faut
c'est ça qu'il faut le savoir donc ça ça
reste ça reste des rien à faire là
dimension humaine reste la dimension
mamie fait nous sommes des mammifères
les mammifères peut-être un peu plus
intelligent enfin c'est la prétention
qu'on en a c'est pas sûr que ça soit
vrai mais mais mais mais ce qui est
important aussi ses doigts que déduit de
ça il ya une intelligence collective qui
s'installe cette intelligence collective
elles forment le réseau elles forment le
réseau et ce réseau l'architecte et
autres traducteurs d'ambition et bien
l'architecte doit montrer comment est-ce
que ce réseau peut s'exprimer en trois
dimensions sur le territoire collectif
pensons que ça c'est important alors il
ya des moyens celle architecture donc
celle architecture ce n'est pas la
construction c'est la différence entre
l'architecturé la construction à 1 100 m
de hiérarchie la construction c'est
francs celle importée
c'est un certain manque ouvrira volume
et puis l'architecte que nous ce que je
suis que nous sommes que sur une
discussion des amis de vie utilisent ont
ces moyens pour dire l'architecturé est
un langage larchitecture dit des choses
on utilise des moyens et nous sommes
dans cette espèce de difficulté ou en
tout cas de plaisir peut-être entre les
sciences humaines et les sciences
exactes nous traduisons d
valeur de sciences humaines avec des
moyens de science exacte il ya une
nouvelle faculté d'architecturé à l'ulb
depuis cinq ans ça a été une
conversation des tirs au but pour savoir
si une versait dans les sciences
humaines ou si on ne versait dans les
sciences exactes
pour finir on a pris une décision à
l'ulb a pris une décision cher aux
shoots east qui fait qu' on est un petit
peu indépendant et ça nous convient
assez bien parce que on a autant d'amis
en sciences humaines que d'amis en
sciences exactes qui nous soutiennent
dans le propos et cette manière de faire
ce réseau est bien c'est celui que nous
utilisons aussi certaines villes chez
art et demi nous avons un réseau nous
insistons sur l'intelligence collective
qui fait qu'il n'ya pas une vérité
d'abord n'y a pas de vérité mais il n'y
a pas une vérité certainement et que
donc c'est simplement la proche de la
vérité qui est cette espèce de challenge
quotidien qui nous anime avec l'ensemble
des partenaires et l'ensemble des
collaborateurs de thémines je pense que
c'est une fois les autres qui pour nous
est très très importante et on tenait à
paris
je continue sur la même image c'est le
dernier projet sur lequel nous sommes
occupés qui est un centre une lampe long
centre d'expérience
bon la base économique et commercial
c'est un centre à barcelone où nous
essayons de montrer qu'il ya à la fois
cette possibilité de montrer que
travaillons en réseau mais que nous
sommes ancrés dans le sol et que les
deux les deux éléments les deux figures
sont importantes
quand on montre une architecture de
nouveau vous voyez que la multiplicité
d'activités donc le réseau s'installe le
réseau s'installe pas seulement sur le
lieu le réseau s'installe aussi dans la
vie nous avons la chance inouïe de
mouthe retrouver pour ceux qui
connaissent barcelone donc barcelone
c'est le plan c'est rare c'est à dire
qu'une toute cette grille et puis qui
est traversée par ce qu'on appelle la
diagonale et d'un côté vous avez la mer
et de l'autre côté nous nous retrouvons
là au bout de l'autre côté de diagonale
pour nous
je dirais un cadeau parce que c'est un
lieu incroyable mais en même temps nous
retirons le tissu du quartier du
quartier du maine où vous voyez qu'il ya
un ensemble de fonctions qui se se
croisent qui s'additionnent qu' il ya
des mouvements il ya la rocade
il ya une université d'ailleurs juste à
côté à l'hôpital des équipements de
sport
je pense que c'est important de dire ça
alors on ajouter ces deux photos là
aussi pourquoi justement pour la
question des réseaux la question des
réseaux regardez cette dame cette dame
est au téléphone
assise dans un bistrot on peut imaginer
que ce soit à namur par exemple elle est
assise elle a un smartphone dans une
oreille elle goûte un café elle a les
pieds sur terre et il entend le bruit de
la vie dit bien ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui peut être le
complément de young boys et c'est à dire
qu'il ya un certain moment mais il faut
lire haïr assises et pas loin
c'est important mais donc pour moi la
hiérarchie c'est d'abord d'avoir les
pieds sur ce une ville par exemple pour
les étudiants qui ont visité des villes
une ville ça s'apprend pas les semelles
c'est à dire qu'il faut marcher marcher
marcher marcher pour comprendre une
ville et puis l'oeil précède toujours le
pas donc un set avant il faut voir les
choses
ici on a quelqu'un qui utilisent ou qui
profitent but de différence pour pouvoir
un certain moment apprécié l'endroit où
elle est en même temps elle est
peut-être entre en conversation avec
quelqu'un qui est à dix mille kilomètres
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre la deuxième
je trouvais intéressante c'est que on
commande par un certain moment de leur
repas par part
interface marque faut y voilà et puis et
puis il ya quand même quelqu'un qui est
à vélo avec un sac sur le dos qui pèse
et qui lui partout du à point a à un
point b la ville en ayant le plaisir ou
en tout cas la sensation de la diff de
la géographie de devoir monter des cours
de le voir descendre devoir devoir
pousser d'avoir mal au genou voilà et
tout ça pour croiser seveso et c'est
important dans cette réflexion nous
comprenions que nous sommes toujours
physique un certain moment nous sommes
toujours physique
heureusement d'ailleurs parce que sinon
ce serait quand même dommage mais on
nous parle pas de chose desquels il faut
faire attention quand je donne tout à
mes étudiants joe dit faites attention
parce qu'on parle de blue city opéré
vers city repart de myxyty qu'est ce que
ça veut dire vous voyez dans l'image en
font au fond à gauche que les cantons on
imagine des villes nouvelles et bien
comme par hasard ce sont toujours des
îles alors que nous nous devons imaginer
tous ensemble quelles que soient nos
compétences nous devons imaginer sévit
noël au milieu de l'héritage que nous
recevons c'est hyper important
ces tirs étaient importants je fais
partie d'une génération dont je veux
dire on peut associer le les difficultés
les flower port de 1970
je pense que c'est eux qui ont démoli le
plus la planète en 50 ans donc si vous
lisez le texte derrière moi j'adhère
complètement si jamais vous ne
connaissez pas cette bd moi qui suis
absolument pas bd je vous conseille de
lire les vieux fond d'eau c'est
l'histoire de change dont 70 ans qui
pensait faire la révolution et tous et
qui à un certain moment mais se retrouve
devant leurs responsabilités
une réflexion c'est difficile je voulais
montrer ça parce que ça c'est le tableau
noir de monde dans ma salle de cours
quand je donne tout bon étudiant là je
viens de l'expliquer
on ne dirait pas comme ça mais je viens
de l'expliquer la problématique d'un
quartier qui s'appelle la gare de
l'ouest à bruxelles et vous voyez que
c'est pas facile quoi c'est pas facile
et ça continue ouais je sis à des
étudiants en art chine en la salle ils
doivent être bien contents de ne pas
suivre mon cours mais
c'est pas facile de 2 alors que là je
vais passer trop rapidement mais si on
regarde le parc de bruxelles par exemple
est celui je ne connais plus on voit
qu'une société s'installe sur son
territoire par rapport à son
organisation
vous avez d'un côté le prince en bas
vous avez le peuple au dessus avec le
parlement et avec eux et avec eux je
n'oublie pas le parlement et le non a
encore avancé qu'avant et le sénat d'un
côté vous avez toutes les ambassades qui
garantissent et notre indépendance en
haut à gauche vous avez le fric avec des
banques
vous avez la culture 1 et puis derrière
l'église n'est jamais loin
le thunder pour garder un petit peu ce
qui se passe pour vérifier un peu ici
tout se passe bien
et donc ce sont des choses qui font que
1 certainement là toute cette réflexion
se traduit aussi par de la cu puisque
j'appelle que nous appelons
l'acupuncture belle des éléments jeunes
est citoyen qui semble d'une faible
dimension mais qui a cumulé les uns aux
autres font finalement que la société
change et c'est important et 7
acupuncture elle peut aussi profiter des
réseaux des réseaux virtuels un certain
vendre pour pouvoir est donc prié le
même dessin mais avec des éléments
d'intervention que ce soit des potagers
urbains que ça soit un certain moment
des maisons cartier que ça choix et ils
ont été élus et aux bruxellois de
l'année pour ceux qui ont suivi un petit
peu l'actualité c'est tous les gens qui
ont aidé les victimes du 22 mars
c'est important de savoir que voilà et
ça ça permet aussi de dire que on peut
avoir aussi une intelligence collective
avec la nature je passerai ma la nature
est intelligente aussi et il faut s'en
préoccuper
il faut se préoccuper et je termine avec
grand plaisir avec la photo de mes
enfants parce que finalement c'est eux
qui m'apprennent j'aurais pu j'aurais pu
terminer avec la photo de mes étudiants
parce que je trouve que en enseignant on
reçoit plus que ce qu on donne on a face
à soi des gens de 20 ans qui ont bouffé
le monde
eh bien je pense que c'est important que
vous bouffer le monde
mais que vous vous levez bouffier avec
cette intelligence de l'interaction
entre le réseau virtuel et le réseau
réel et de garder les pieds sur terre
je vous remercie
[Musique]